tabes up guys my name is a Chenoweth
episode 29 of game programming so in the
previous episode we took all that this
render tile class and how that sort of
works and actually we sort of took a
look specifically at the offsets now the
officers work and you know the concept
of offsets of course is very important
in in game programming and today we're
just going to move on to completing this
round detail method it method and
talking about a little about how how
tiles actually you know get rented into
our screen in the end now you might have
noticed I'm sort of using a different
version of Eclipse I'm actually using
eclipse
junot now now by default one thing that
I hated about Juno and I'll actually
tell you why I changed my Eclipse
version in a minute but one thing about
Juno was protip here in general and an
appearance by default it's set to
Windows 7 theme I hate that so set it
back to classic and it'll change it back
to what Eclipse Helius and what Eclipse
um indigo actually looked like and
you'll be fine without all right
animations as well I haven't actually
yeah this fading this fading stuff I
might just get rid of that as well
because I I'm used to the there we go Oh
much better
alright so um
uh yeah one of the things you actually
notice is if I run the game I actually
got a new computer I actually built
myself a new computer so you can see
that the framerate pretty much doubled
so be warned you know I didn't actually
change any code you haven't missed
anything the game is still running at
the same speed for you guys it should be
I just upgraded to a faster computer so
that's why that's why the framerate
doubled
anyway back to back to this I'll just
adjust my microphone because it's kind
of getting annoying alright so um so
yeah let's take a look at this so in in
game programming in general you know
we're sort of dealing in a
two-dimensional uh like spectrum right
now right we've got x and y to deal with
so a good like a good thing to just just
think about is whatever we do to Y we
typically actually have to do two X as
well because we're trying to do it in
two dimensions right so because of that
we literally just copy and paste this
again and we change all the Y's into X's
right because we want to be able to do
the same thing in terms of off-site and
in terms of offsets for X as well and
you might have to oops
one too many you might have to seal that
as well alright so again obviously the
tiles are square which is why the tiles
bright size is you know it's the same
width as it is length so we don't have
to change this at all but everything
else gets changed into exhale and that's
sort of what happens right with the
offsets we can offset through Y now we
can offset through X as well so the next
thing we need to do is actually restrict
our screen so you can see here that we
had this continued thing and what and
what what would happen is if we would
get if if we got to the the edge of the
screen it would sort of cut it off so
that we wouldn't get any array index out
of bounds exception now we're going to
do exactly the same thing here so a bit
differently so if X a so again if this X
a which remember is not just the x
position of the sprite it's also the
offset so in other words is the it's the
absolute x position except X absolute
if it's less than I will just say less
than zero I'll set it less than zero for
now just because I want to show you guys
what will happen if I actually set it
less than zero instead of not a
different value because it's actually a
really cool fact that I'll show you guys
in a bit but um that if X a is so that's
how I said that that obviously means all
so if X a is less than 0 or X a is
greater than and equal to
ah it's greater than or equal to a width
so with obviously is referring to our
almighty screen with all Y is less than
zero or Y is greater than equal to width
then we want to break and oh I did
remember my um ctrl shift F things
that's nice alright um yeah so obviously
what this code is saying is if for
example a tile which we exit the screen
stop rendering that tile okay if we
don't do this it won't necessarily give
us an array index out of bounds
exception but what we'll do definitely
is take up system resources if we don't
really want to render the entire map if
we're just in a really small portion of
this now because what what I'm saying
here is only render the tiles that we
see theoretically that the size of our
map could actually be pretty much
infinite and of course what I'm talking
about programming and computers and
technology the word infinite means
pretty much infinite not really because
obviously you can't imagine any numbers
can't do that but what I mean is
realistically the number is very high
that is how much the only dealing
restraint here really is the RAM and how
much you can actually how many tiles
objects with with the x and y
coordinates and the type of the tiler
can actually create so what this does
and what what like the way that I'm
going to structure this is that the maps
are basically going to be infinite now
what that few things that that means I'm
going to get more into into actually map
creation a bit later on but
another cool thing would be um we could
have a minecraft style random generation
going on probably at a much simpler
scale though because again we don't need
Z we're not doing well doing in 3d here
but what I mean is because you know the
maps are infinite we could have
something like that going on and that
would actually be relatively easy to
create because of the way that we're
sort of doing this because again
remember this is a 2-d game we're not
storing things like 3d models of maps
there's it's a lot easier to actually
create larger Maps so think of wrong
with the mad god but all the realms are
something are in one or something like
Skyrim think of Skyrim but every
location is already loaded into into
your into one file so um yeah like the
whole of the whole of the world is like
one file that's very possible so again
when we actually do make critical
decisions as to how maps work I'll get
you guys in as well maybe like a poll or
do like a poll on Facebook so that you
guys can vote for how we're going to do
that so I'm really excited to be able to
do that in the future but for now what
you need to understand is this line of
code here is very important because it
um it essentially it's it grants our
state ability is basically if you miss
this line of code I don't actually know
if the game will crash I'm guessing it
will but it whether it will actually I
don't think a will um no well it
definitely will but um the
one is make sure you only render what
you can see on the screen okay that's
your lesson for today make sure you're
only rendering and you're only actually
using resources for what is visible on
your screen next line of cones next line
of code is going to be pretty simple
simply going to render the tire RDM it's
going to render it's going to render the
tile onto the screen right so again it's
pretty much the same as this here so
pixels x a plus y a times width equals
sprite so this time we're not actually
accessing a static sprite we're sorry
actually we're accessing this tile so
tile dot sprite tile dots bright dot
pixels and then of course we're just
going to do now this is actually
something that you guys might be
confused by we're not actually going to
do offsets because again we don't need
to deal with offsets it's just one
sprite the look this is this deals with
where the sprite gets rounded like in
other words which pixels on the screen
get rendered and this deals with which
pixels of the sprite get rendered so
obviously at no point in time us our
pixels on this sprite actually offset so
in other words that's why we need to
deal with x and y naught X naught X a
and y a because we're not dealing with
offsets here the tile does not the
actual image of the tile does not get
offset its location on that on the
screen does so X plus y and then x tile
does sprite dot size and that is it so
that is how the render tile method works
tomorrow or so the day after tomorrow
we'll we'll actually get on to making um
well we'll actually get on to rendering
tile so in other words you can see in
the tail method us are in the UM yeah in
our class tile for example in the render
method of that we're actually using that
but we will utilize this Renat our thing
- hopefully render a entire level full
of grass tiles next time but that is how
the render tile works and I hope you
enjoyed this episode
of game programming if you did please
hit that like button and and yeah we'll
move on to will move on to actually
rendering hit next time so I'll see you
guys later bye
you